i've been getting more and more emails
with people asking about my perspective
on the current market instability and by
market this includes the stock market
and this includes crypto markets as well
i mean at this point
crypto is mainstream enough that cnbc is
talking about the price of bitcoin it's
it's it's just a reality
and um you know in in situations like
this
my
primary tool
is not thinking i have any special skill
insight knowledge or intelligence at all
and saying given that what are the
things that i can do historically
so that i don't make irrational and
rushed decisions you know i get
all sorts of different newsletters in
the personal finance space et cetera
and all of these anecdotes of people
saying you know as soon as the market
crashed i sold everything and i'm going
to try to get back in later at a lower
price
that typically doesn't work the markets
are at their historic highs
a shockingly high percentage of the time
i don't remember exactly it's something
like you know 15 something like that um
the number doesn't even matter i don't
believe i have any ability to say now i
should sell to get back in lower later
bitcoin all over the place the situation
in kazakhstan and all these different
things what am i doing i'm doing nothing
i'm only going back to certain specific
principles which i'm going to outline in
a moment for you
where it doesn't matter what's happening
these are principles that always apply i
want to mention this
video is sponsored by policy genius they
make buying life insurance really simple
i'm going to talk about insurance in a
moment
not life insurance life insurance is
something that can give you a big
feeling of comfort i'm going to talk
about other types of insurance later in
this segment but life insurance lets you
know people who are important to you are
covered if there's someone relying on
you it's a good idea to consider life
insurance it's generally pretty
affordable you don't have to spend a lot
of money on it and it gets more
expensive as you get older so it can
make sense to lock in a better price
sooner than later which is often the way
it works with policy genius you click
the link below answer a few questions
you can see personalized quotes and find
your best price you could save 50
percent or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius it's
straightforward they really do
everything for you including the
paperwork
it costs you nothing to use policy
genius they don't sell your information
and those are all really really good
things go to policygenius.com david
pakman show to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save now what am i doing in the
market instability circumstances in
which we find ourselves endless articles
is this the end of the bull market
i have no idea
what should we be doing in terms of when
do you but no that's market timing i
don't do anything so here are the
principles i'm using and this is not
advice to anyone in particular but it's
what i'm doing number one
i am not selling anything
first of all
it's the timing issue that i mentioned i
have no idea if this is a good time to
sell
my favorite holding period is
indefinitely
secondly
i am continuing to accumulate assets
based on the asset allocation that i
have outlined so if you're 80 20 stocks
to bonds if you're doing three to five
percent crypto you know all things that
that are kind of in in my universe i'm
just continuing to do that and when
prices go down
your same hundred or thousand or ten
thousand dollars or whatever
gets you more shares or gets you more
coins or whatever so if you have chosen
your asset allocation based on your
long-term
view of these assets stocks bonds crypto
cash whatever
if prices go down it's not logical to
sell presumably you have chosen this
asset allocation because you think over
the long time asset values will go up
now if you unlike me
think that you can time the market
all power to you to do whatever you want
but it's not what i'm doing and then as
far as insurance goes one of the things
i always do at the beginning of the year
is i want to make sure
that i am properly insured in all areas
so when it comes to car home etc this
this is not part of the sponsorship
policy genius does life insurance i do
review and make sure okay given that
there is volatility in different places
do i still have my emergency fund in
place so i can meet three to six months
of expenses if income goes to zero
without selling or moving around any
assets do i have the right coverage on
my home do i have the right coverage on
my car umbrella as well in media we have
other types of insurance as well that's
what i'm doing and i am not trying to do
anything that would require me having
special knowledge am i in the right
asset allocation yes then i'm gonna keep
buying
and you can rebalance annually to get
back in proportion to that allocation
that you've determined as the right one
am i properly covered in terms of
insurance risk well then i just sit and
wait which has been my strategy really
for the last
16 years since i started my investment
and retirement accounts that's what i'm
doing
it may not apply to you
but with so many people asking me have
you sold because of what's been going on
the answer is i have not i'm just
continuing to buy but not extra just
what i plan to do originally